all right before we get started everyone
thinks the sponsor of this video this
video is brought to you by
magic spoon breakfast cereal sponsorship
absolutely breakfast is the most
important meal of the day folks let us
not trivialize that also this is a one
division video
so magic spoon has zero grams of sugar
13 grams of protein and only 4 grams of
carbs in each serving
also only 140 calories it's also keto
friendly gluten free grain free soy free
low carb and gmo free
and magic spoon just came out with a
variety pack featuring four exciting
flavors
a fact so epic for showing it to you
here in full cinema color
and if you mix peanut butter and cocoa
it tastes just like peanut butter cups
take that parents and magic spoon is so
confident with their product they offer
a 100
happiness guarantee so click the link
below to go to magicspoon.com
john's and be sure to use promo code
john's for five dollars off your order
and thank you once again to magic spoon
for sponsoring this video
we do appreciate it alright so one
division
episode second to last now this is the
backstory of juan division well
backstory for wanda
and agatha harkness now that the cat's
out of the bag from the last episode
where she was like i'm
agatha the harkness in case you're
wondering agatha's now trying to figure
out how
wanda has all this power where'd she get
the power to create this reality from
she got the power where we get all of
our power where all of us get power
power and nostalgia baby have you been
paying attention through this
nostalgic pop culture boom which is
funny because now we know everything's
been a sitcom because
wanda watched a lot of sitcoms which i
had that
did did i say that in the video did i
cut it out anyhow i was like was she
watching a lot of sitcoms in the super
evil hydra dungeon guess so so we get
walked through wanda's backstory we also
get agatha harkness's backstory which
it kind of felt tacked on this episode
starts out with that backstory she's in
the salem witch trials she's
gonna get burned at the stake 1693
cancelled as it's known as they're not
burned at the stake but they try to
magic her to death
fine give me the rated pg version so i
didn't need it yeah i could have just
heard about it like
zemo you know when he was just talking
about why he was doing what he was doing
you saw
the events around him he didn't see him
but you know you got where he was coming
from so the fact that they were so
hard-pressed to be like here's agatha's
backstory i feel like she might
die i feel like she's gonna end where
she started in wong division but the big
takeaway is
wanda in fact did make this reality this
this hex as it's known as but there's a
caveat there
not everything was as we were told
because we were told by director dick
that she went down got vision's body and
well
now visions in this hex not so this
guy's like wanda i get it you you want
to say goodbye division come to me to
this chop shop
trust me this is not going to be brutal
and then she sees them just dismantling
vision's body and you think oh she's
going to go down there and take the body
no she's like bye vision
uh i hope the folks here treat you well
this sucks i'm out and she leaves so
that's not
vision inside the one division world
inside that
bubble reality that's a vision she
created through the power of nostalgia
in her mind so he's not the vision
he's the dream
i'm cutting that out now you know what
[ __ ] it it's stank which i was
floored when director dick look that's
just what i know him as
that's what i call him when he was like
look i i get you want to say goodbye but
i'm not just gonna let you put eight
billion dollars
however much was it four eight billions
of dollars of vibranium into the ground
i was like
but how much money a vibranium is in
vision's body
i thought one thing how much is cap's
shield worth
this is why i'm just not worthy to be
captain i can never be captain america
i'm not worthy of mjolnir i'm worthy i'm
none of it because when i've moved
i you know i wrap up the hot toys and
people are helping me move i'm like
careful careful they're bubble wrap but
careful the collector's items
you know i'll take it i'll take that box
i'll take it so if i was cap and i had a
shield and i was fighting thanos to be
like
wait dude chill out you know what this
is worth it's a collector's item this is
my retirement plan but cap does not care
about such things
that's why he's cat but after the shield
was busted up
effectively useless couldn't chip you
know
couldn't you i mean there's a market i'm
just saying but this does have a mid
credit scene where director dick is like
oh
that drone that she threw at us that has
her power in it
so we're gonna use that to animate the
vision funny enough vision's missing no
parts it's it's all him i mean he's a
pasty white looking but it's all him no
one kept just you know a pinky
a toe just enough to pay the mortgage
off put the kids through college
bishop's like i'm going to get you i uh
something's missing but at first i was
like so director rita repulsa made the
evil green ranger you know like making
the evil version of the good guy that's
like
i don't know it's just been done a lot
but
it's been done a lot because that's
those are comic books that's a
comic book arc right there this is a
comic book
show it's like nothing's more comic book
than that so it makes sense for the
universe i don't know after that it was
kind of cool but then i was just amazed
that it took that
many years of the mcu how long has the
mc you've been around just shy of 12
years now it'll be 12 years this may it
took
12 years to do the whole oh the bad
version
of the good guy thing we haven't seen
the evil version of the good guy and
maybe now we'll see the dream fight the
double vision
if he is a bad version who knows he
might just come out of that be like
oh i have glowing eyes and i look a
little different but
have any of you heard of voltaire i
really love philosophy they can be like
oh god that's our weapon or he's going
to be more of the ultron
side of his parenthood you know he's
made from
ultron and jarvis and he said i'm
neither ultron nor jarvis
just like neither of us out there none
of us are actually our parents we'll see
interesting stuff i love me a good
backstory i thought the agatha harkness
backstory didn't need it the wanda stuff
filled in a bit of her backstory i
really loved that scene where her and
vision
are talking shortly after quicksilver
was killed that was a good scene we
haven't gotten enough
of those two before vision dies it was a
good scene to have
and now we know she really loves sitcoms
something we had never seen before
because i'm pretty sure they didn't
think that far ahead i get it before if
someone asks what are wandas likes
they'd be like well um
tall drapes and pronouncing paprika so
they filled in the sitcom thing but i'm
glad she was the one who made this
reality out of pain because when it was
like oh i get the harkness i was like
that's not as cool as wanda making this
to escape you know to find happiness she
took a note
from the train ghost from ghost took all
of her emotions all her anger all her
love all her hate and pushed it way down
here into the pit of her stomach and
then exploded like a reactor
pow and created this whole reality
granted agatha i guess
made not quick silver quick nickel
quick pewter they do say the term your
truth a lot in this show
this show that deals with reality so i'm
always like
i think the term you're looking for is
your reality like did the audio say
yanny or laurel the answer that you hear
is your reality the truth is it has to
do with pitch and whether you're
registering high frequency
love frequency you know so truth isn't
necessarily reality they're different
things
it just cracks me up all right so one
division episode eight second to the
last episode did you like the backstory
stuff what did you think of agatha's
backstory what'd you think of wanda's
backstory and all of that stuff with
vision also would you
look just a pinky a fingernail something
me neither
that'd be terrible whatever you think
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]
you